my listenership skews young and excused
male
and relative i would argue were kind of
relative to every other cohort and some
of it
is a good thing in overdue but relative
to other cohorts
young men are failing and that is
they're not making they're not making as
much progress
as some other cohorts and i'm wondering
what advice
you have or what advice you would give
to your younger self or what advice you
would give to
to young men kind of you know just
starting out in their career
in terms of their professional approach
and i'd love to hear your thoughts or
your learnings about trying to be
you know a good dad and a good husband i
think it's a massive
under uh discussed topic that young men
are failing in the united states of
america
but it's true and it's in the numbers
i mean you can see it at every level one
of the things i say in my book scott
um that and i think you were raised by a
single mom that's right right
yeah i'm a child of a single immigrant
mother who lived and died a secretary
our household income was never more than
uh forty thousand dollars uh and a warm
hand of government literally
grabbed me by the scruff of my neck and
threw me forward
and i worry that that warm hand is no
longer as big and as caring as it used
to be
but yeah i'm the son of a single
immigrant mother yeah
so today 40 of
kids are born into
single-parent households uh and 90 of
the time single parent household is
single mother yep
and if you look at the the data uh
little girls who grow up with single
moms actually have okay outcomes
um in part because girls are more
adaptable they're better at school
earlier
they've got a strong female role model
they see super mom
but if you have a little boy in that
setting um it turns out that little boys
and i i'm the father to two young boys
myself
so i can see why this is the case but
apparently little boys are more
sensitive to parental time and input and
the lack thereof
than little girls like they they they're
they're more
subject to uh variability that way
um and so the outcomes around boys
brought up by single moms
there are more adverse uh academic um
progressions more behavioral issues
and the data is not great um and
and to me a lot of the problems that
that we see
like cascade from from there where you
send them to these schools that aren't
really equipped
for people at different maturation
levels and it turns out that boys often
mature at different
rates than whatever the grade level is
supposed to be
and then at the college level the last i
checked i think is something like
um 43 percent of undergrads are men like
57
70 of high school valedictorians are
young women now
think about that yeah so so so you have
uh you have
boys and men coming of age and then you
have an economy that has become
increasingly punishing and uninviting
like it used to be if you were a guy
with a high school um education you
could get like a factory job and like
you know union household middle class
life like like all that stuff's gotten
decimated
you know we've gotten rid of four
million manufacturing jobs and the rest
of it
um and then you have a culture that like
that looks at
men and being like hey whatever happened
it's your fault you know it's
like that it's like every room we walked
into for the last 400 years we've been
right and all of a sudden everyone we
walk into right now we're wrong
so it's like crimea river but i do see
young men feeling like
kind of they feel like they're you know
they're in this nether netherland right
now
and as a young guy myself i mean i
remember vividly when my company failed
in my 20s and like you know you're like
like down on your luck and your
confidence is shot um
it's hard because i at least speaking
for myself like you had this real
thirst to try and make something of
yourself and when it feels like you
can't make something of yourself you can
like eat yourself alive it's humiliating
it's like that yeah in my case my
failure was very public everyone knew
that i tried to start this company and
that it was a flop and that like
the rest of it so because you know if
you start something you kind of have to
tell everyone you're doing it and then
when it dies then like everyone
sees it so it felt like for a while like
no one was calling me and the
the rest of it and i remember lying on
my floor being like
what did i do and like i owed this
hundred thousand in debt um
and i i think it is something where uh
you know many many
men are not being or americans generally
but men i think
to a higher degree like there isn't like
a clear path forward
um and so you know like my guidance
um would be to focus on the things that
you know you can
control that will give you like at least
some form of
self-development or the worst case
scenario at least like comfort where
it's like in my
case when things went south in my 20s
like i established some fitness goals
for myself i was like well
like sure i'm a failure but at least
i'll be a fit failure
[Laughter]
i'll have a six-pack
or or it could be like something around
a relationship
where you know it's like you turn around
and say look most of my friends
like you know aren't calling me now but
you know this one friend is calling me
and so like i'm gonna try and like
um uh pay attention to the positives in
my life
um try and learn i mean a lot of people
who listen to your podcast are trying to
develop their business savvy
um and so that's something that i did
like i tried to find people who knew
more than i did which was everyone
and then learn from them one thing that
helped me a lot in that direction is
reading books
um i think podcasts are great but i
think reading books um
to me was like the best way to feel like
i got inside someone's head
um and was getting a bit of like
uh wisdom um the single most concrete
thing that happened for me
positively and professionally um and
this is advice i'd give to anyone is
like just try and find someone who
uh is ahead of you on a path that you
want and then just say like look i will
do anything under the sun for you i
don't care what
it pays or doesn't pay i don't care what
you assign me like i'll take out the
garbage i don't care
but just like my being uh are able to
like demonstrate my value to that person
in that setting um would be
setting me up for at least some degree
of development on the path that i wanted
and so in my case after my company died
there was like a more
established entrepreneur who's like hey
join my my little company
and i just saw this guy and was like
this guy is someone that
i'd want to be when i grow up and so
like whatever this guy wants me to do
i'll do
um and so if you can find someone who
you look up to in that respect
um just try and add value for them in
any form
and then you'll find yourself becoming a
little bit more like them
over time what about any thoughts on
being a
a good husband and a good father i mean
like you know i mean it's a constant
struggle you know it's like you can be a
good dad one day and then the next dad
the next day like you know like uh be be
a
less exemplary parent um it's the same
being a partner
it's like you're married and i mean i'm
just like the luckiest guy to be married
to evelyn like she put up with so
much stuff um and appreciates me for the
things that i
do bring to the table um and you know i
just have to i tell her
i appreciate her as often as i tell her
i love her
and so a lot of a lot of the struggle
i've had to deal with
i think that many people can relate to
is just trying to be grateful
like because it's so easy to start
getting down on yourself
or your relationships and be like oh
like i have a document on my phone
that's literally it's like okay here are
the things i'm grateful for
and then anytime i see myself spiraling
in a negative way or like snapping at my
kid or like
snapping at um you know like someone who
doesn't deserve it i'll be like wait a
minute like
i hadn't seen my kids in like months and
i missed them terribly and like now i'm
around them and i'm like
not appreciating it like you know like
you try and like get get some
perspective
um and in my case it's helpful to have a
document i actually refer to where it's
like here are the things i'm grateful
for
and some of the things are stupid you
know some of the things are like oh i'm
really grateful for my
like uh for that pizza place i really
like chipotle i'm grateful for chipotle
every day
yeah yeah right you have chipotle on
your list you'd be like oh i love that
place like
good for that um so it's like appreciate
the little things and the big things
and in terms of your accomplishments
have some really easy wins for yourself
too it's like look
i can't control my professional path
today but i can make sure i get
like uh you know a little bit of nature
in or some push-ups in or whatever the
hell it is
like give yourself some things that you
are actually very very
achievable and basic and that could be
like appreciating chipotle
and what i'm curious you're talking
about i think fitness is
i mean fitness is my antidepressant i
think it's something that young people
need to embrace at an
early age for a lot of reasons what's
your fitness routine
uh well in quarantine it's been a little
different
like like i i had a weekly basketball
game
um that was like the centerpiece of my
mental health
um but now it's uh calisthenics
riding a bike playing with the kids
good for you thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know every time we have a
new episode